[Music]
well the record lucky size usually in
anime I wouldn't touch with a ten-foot
barge fault I took one look at the art
and I could already hear every girl in
my head given a sounding ah other sides
of pretty colors and cute little girls
dressed in mini school uniforms before
going off and doing more girly things
like applying makeup and talking about
lesbian sex and yes all girls do talk
about lesbian sex in their spare time
since this is my mind and I can
fantasize about whatever the hell I want
anyway the other reason I'm doing this
is because Water Works productions
requested that I do review of the first
episode of lucky star now I don't
believe that you can review an anime
just by watching one episode so this is
more of a first impression of the show
and my opinions in this video are
subject to change if I actually decide
to watch the rest of the series when I
was trying to find a synopsis of the
show I immediately notice that many
people described the anime as being a
show about nothing it's per my curiosity
since when I heard it was a show about
nothing I thought hmm the show about
nothing
that sounds pretty interesting but to my
disappointment when I've watched it it
was a show about nothing which really
wasn't as cool as it sounded in my head
or maybe that's just me
the first thing that really hit me about
lucky star was the opening I'll surprise
when I put on the first episode I was
greeted by a noise equivalent to the
collective sound of about a hundred
fangirls willing simultaneously largest
called glimpse of Brad Pitt
either that or epilepsy in the end I
wasn't sure how I should have reacted to
probably most schizophrenic opening ever
created it was the most annoying yet at
the same time addictive opening I've
witnessed the experience could probably
be replicated by taking an acid trip
through Vegas while listening to 1400
Chipmunks sing Japanese karaoke of DDR
songs was high on speed ice at that yen
running what the hell I just watch and
that set the tone for the whole episode
I said it's now said they're waiting for
the end of the video I didn't get the
show or at least the episode I watched
it was ten minutes in before I began to
realize I just watched ten minutes of
four girls talking about lesbian sex now
they'd like to get it on with each other
okay maybe that wasn't what the girls
were talking about but my mind drifted
and I was probably more interesting than
what they were talking about anyway
since they spend a full 10 minutes
talking about food and how to eat it he
just kept dragging on and I find myself
drifting off all the time wondering if
it will actually pick up it really was
this fun then drowning ten minutes of
uninteresting conversation later
and I was left wondering how I became so
popular and how did I'd be able to get
back the past twenty minutes of my life
maybe I wasn't enough of a key to get it
considering that I've had more
engrossing conversations with my ass and
some of the stuff in this episode he
also didn't help that I had little to no
knowledge of any references that I've
heard makes this show so popular it's
like you were invited to a party by a
friend you didn't really know but
decided to go anyway upon arrival we
find out everyone is already in their
own group of friends or who have their
own buzzwords and in jokes that you just
don't yet and in the end you'll just end
up standing at the edge of the group
looking awkward made
dude that guy watching lux thought made
me feel like that guy in the sense that
I felt everyone else watching it was
laughing well I just sat there chuckling
awkwardly to myself in my best attempts
understand the jokes I also got the
feeling that the other reason that luck
stars popular is a certain character
named kanata mainly because connector
represents about 99.9% of the target
demographic ie you and partly because
it's impossible for the nerves not to
get a huge nerd stiffy when we find out
it's the same person who voice Harry he
even if in this case is from a character
that doesn't look like she to reach
puberty yet though I suppose it's
acceptable to get huge nerd snippy's two
characters whose collective ages add up
to about 12 these days as long as
they're Japanese and you can perfectly
accept that they're in high school and
still keep a straight face all in all I
could see what people would like this
but I just don't think it's my type of
man mate who knows maybe the series is
completely different off to the first
episode that she becomes entertaining
perhaps I'll have to wait till I've seen
more anime or play more games or become
fat and overweight completely lose my
sex life before this anime appeals to me
until then
I'll leave the rabid fan base to its own
devices all I've tried to compensate my
loss of testosterone by doing manly
things like work out and talk about will
never think about lesbian sex all day
[Music]